i also can't not ask you about your
experience working on argo so
i'm sure you go into a situation like
that having certain assumptions about
ben affleck so is there anything that he
did on that set
as a director that kind of pleasantly
surprised you
he is also i've i've generally honestly
gotten so
lucky like i feel like all the huge name
people i've worked with have been
wonderful
um so i i feel really like
grateful for that but ben affleck also
similarly was just like so generous with
this energy and he's a
very down-to-earth person like he i was
really nervous it was my first major
major motion picture i loved saying that
and it was like a heavy hitting cast
with like
john goodman and like all these cool
people and
i just felt like this like rookie and he
just disarms you right away
like he created such a safe like warm
feeling
place that i actually genuinely felt
like i could do good work because i
wasn't so intimidated like i'll shut
down i don't work well with like more
kind of tyrannical
filmmakers he's not like that at all and
i i don't know if it's because he's an
actor himself like he seemed to really
respect our process
and he wanted things to feel natural for
us
he wanted us to feel comfortable um and
he just like in general just has such a
like warm
and friendly energy that he doesn't come
off as this like
guarded i'm a celebrity i'm untouchable
at all he's and i think that's like
kind of like what he's been known for a
lot in his
career is like he's played a lot of
these like
everyday guys and stuff and um
yeah it was it was it was an environment
where i felt like
everyone got to shine a bit even though
it was a big ensemble piece
and um he was so supportive
it was really really nice like i i he
didn't
in a situation like that like being one
of the only
iranian actors in this movie and like
having a smaller supporting part it's
it's i can't tell you how often like i
have been kind of just overlooked and
like
mistaken for an extra even when i'm like
number sev you know like high up on the
call sheet or a principal actor like
not that there's anything wrong with
being an extra i'm just saying like come
on i've been here every day you've been
seeing me like
my bad invisible to you but it wasn't
like that on argo at all like
ben affleck always made me feel like i
was an important part of this story
and even in the way that like he had me
come in and do the voiceover for the
beginning of the film
and he also added a scene to the end of
the film where you see my character
escaping iran because they had done it
shown it to a few test audiences who
actually like wanted to know what
happened with my character which was
like really great
but also like he made that choice as the
director that like that was important to
him too
and he he wanted to add that so i i felt
really seen by him and like
like he um yeah he was he just included
me in that
in that group in a way that like i don't
think i normally necessarily would have
been included
you